peter brown you have a game here to play
uh
and i'm gonna watch you play it what is
this game and just describe it to me
you bastard this is rock of ages two
this is a sequel to a game from 2011.
describing it to you is not so easy it's
a mix of
uh tower defense and boulder simulation
okay
um clearly heavily inspired by some of
the old monty python stuff
big fan of that what's the the artists
that helped them out terry gillum terry
gilliam yes
lots of his stuff fantastic fantastic uh
so let's jump in i i could start the
story campaign but i think i might start
from the beginning
okay yeah you're right this is very much
cutouts even the same era right oh we
got some braveheart scotland
i am william wallace william wallace is
seven feet tall
yes of her he kills men by the hundreds
and if he were here he'd consume the
english with fireballs from his eyes
and bolts of lightning from his arse i
am william wallace
and i see
oh my god this is so money python
yeah you were not lying this is great
though i don't lie
that's one thing you should know about
me i never tell a lie
a little little morpheus action here
it knows what it does awesome okay so
the basic premise is that yourself and
an opponent you each have
a it's like a castle but essentially
there's something in the middle of the
castle you're protecting
okay and the only way that'll come under
threat is if the door on the front of it
gets busted and that'll get busted by a
boulder
now yourself and your opponent you have
boulders uh here are two examples
there's the lion boulder
i got that by beating king richard a wee
babe
uh and then i also have the rock of ages
which is the standard one i still
clearly have a ways to go you use these
boulders and you try to ram into these
doors and every time you throw a boulder
and roll it and hit their door
you have to wait to chip away at a new
one so i'll just get started you'll
it'll make more sense once i'm going
here
so you'll see on the in the bottom left
corner here we've got my health bar
right and we've got some some gentlemen
some dudes some guys some men
uh building my boulder they're carving
out a rock
so in this phase what i want to do
uh this is where my boulder is these
little shortcuts i'm clicking
this is where the castle is being my
castle
uh i want to build anything i can to
slow down that boulder as i just
described
uh so the trick is you have some money
to spend every turn
you don't need to spend all of it
because ultimately as long as you slow
down the boulder at the last second
uh it will only have this amount of
space
to build up speed right so at that point
it'll only get like a minimum
you know amount of damage gotcha and the
opponent can control and you yourself
yes control the boulder yes i can defy
the laws of physics and i can have my
boulder slow down i can make it go
faster turn left or right
whatever okay uh so the ultimate goal is
to break through that door
and squash the king that resides inside
with the boulder uh which is pretty fun
so
i lost the last time i played scotland
uh so i don't know if i'm gonna win here
but we're certainly gonna try
yeah okay [ __ ] here we go we're both
rolling never mind what i was saying
uh so you're watching his feet too yeah
so what i want to do is i
really want to be able to go as fast as
possible you really are in full control
yeah and i want to avoid any obstacles i
can so that i have
and i can jump too oh my god
and i want to be able to go as fast as i
can so i can again
uh hit his wall with as much force as
possible and me and him are both on
pretty much the same cooldown timer and
everything oh
no it's okay it's okay you can you can
lose the boulder here and it'll pick
back up
oh am i gonna make it on my own no okay
it's fine it'll be you lost your speed
it'll reject me i lost my speed
chances are i would have done something
that would have lost speed but more
importantly rob i lost time
oh precious seconds uh
now that didn't hurt my boulder too much
but these various uh obstacles that you
can
see uh do actually hurt the boulder and
diminish
the amount of strength it has sorry but
that was really good that actually took
out almost
he half as much he didn't have anything
in the end there huh
uh no he didn't because he's an idiot
apparently yeah uh but me i'm not an
idiot so i'm going to refortify here
uh i've got 4 20 50
to spend so it's okay
his boulder came through and did a
little bit less damage than mine
now the problem is i cannot rebuild
where you have already
already built right so you want to leave
enough space yeah
no i didn't do a great job of that but
that's okay
so it's more than just that though right
like you need to buy yourself time so
you also want to do
things like build on bridges not right
right not mean i do i do and if you can
knock him off
ahead of time then he'll fall off a
cliff and again he'll lose time as well
right so the thing is is that maybe not
here because there's houses but certain
areas here
if i built a wall and he's good enough
at controlling his boulder he can snake
around
and not lose speed so you really want to
pick and choose where you're setting up
these obstacles again
like blind spots and stuff blind spots
in places that have
as you know as many obstacles as
possible so here is for speed
you know to stop his speed and then here
at the bridge is to stop
him even progressing and hopefully make
him fall off okay my next boulder is
ready to go
so the reason that my obstacles don't
get in the way of my own boulder is
because we
are working on two separate uh but
identical maps they're essentially
mirrors of one another
so we face the same constraints and the
same rules but we have
uh our own independent fields if you
will
right oh yeah
that's me nice moves oh
sorry so where you're looking is is the
is where you're turning
i'm literally just staring straight
ahead and holding my breath as i guide
this
rock but as far as the controls like
is it like it's not candy that's not
camera no it's wasd
soon if i turn the camera even if i turn
the camera
that doesn't change my forward it's free
look
yeah oh this is good this is good this
is looking good scotland is off their
game because i'm dunking on them
oh [ __ ] that sucked that was half you
look like you okay look at me now so now
i'm losing actually
so you kind of missed the door a little
bit there no i i absolutely missed the
door a lot of bit there i'm sorry i was
being nice
no that's why we all like you so much
so what else do you have you have walls
you have turrets towers
i got so the the catapults that i could
have had they don't really work on their
own
what do you mean uh they don't work
independently so you have to like click
on them and control them
oh which is a real pain in the ass now
you do also in a similar vein have this
no resource cost essentially a free
attack which is this lightning bolt
cloud
it's not a cooldown timer so i can
summon that cloud and it'll hit
a number of squares in its vicinity but
it's uh it's tricky
it doesn't always hit the thing that you
wanted to hit i'm gonna lose to scotland
again i can't i can't do this
chances are we're gonna i'm gonna lose
and we're gonna go back to the first
round of this so i
can look better okay that's fine oh
it's not fine no i mean we got to see
what it's like to lose
so i can't cast a lightning cloud
anywhere near here
it's starting point oh [ __ ] i got no
time for that
keep the good times rolling they say
yeah yeah yeah
all right oh [ __ ]
oh no that was a long drop too
thank you so
did he put those barrels down uh i
believe he did so he has access to
things that i don't have access
to because why uh just because of the
skill
apparently he's better than me okay okay
he's
he's simply just i'm i'm lesser than
compared to him
if you catch my drift
oh boy
so i believe the first game was a
connect game on 360.
oh i don't even know if it came out for
pc i remember
seeing the oh what catapults i don't
have those
oh my god so i think i so the reason i
might be losing this match is because
i'm at a disadvantage
yeah and i think that's not necessarily
the game's fault
i think that i literally didn't explore
the map enough to acquire the things i
wanted
it's up to the next boulder that that's
really all it looks like
go i don't care which boulder pick one
go man he had i was watching his his uh
his feed he was making
some major momentum in the last stretch
yeah
yeah i think you should put it looked
like it to me yeah so i can okay okay i
can do that
but it doesn't really matter at this
point it's whatever rock gets off first
you get your rocks and you get that [ __ ]
no i love it
i'm an idiot um it's uh we're doing fine
uh i mean really this is the best case
scenario because when i win it's gonna
feel awesome
i want that that's yeah i also like to
feel awesome
okay i can sense the rock come on come
on come on come on i gotta tap i gotta
tap c
so do you have any kind of like
progression tree that you can like
invest into like tech on so i think on
the map you basically just roll around
the map and i think you can discover oh
[ __ ] oh that bastard tricky [ __ ]
oh my god you landed directly on that oh
man reggie like a book
damn it are these gusts of wind that are
also a factor
maybe i can't talk right now yeah that's
fine
oh i refuse to lose that rock saved your
life
oh my god bart
so you jump on okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay i want to rock
[Music]
yeah yes yes yes yes yes
william wallace and then you crush him
i've come for your bones
oh see i told you this was the right way
to win
well it's tight yeah wait wait wait wait
wait where's his stuff
between his legs wait what i mean ain't
got no stuff
oh right reminds me of my own body
me too actually uh dang
that was a close one i've not played
this okay let's try it out
you know what sucks uh there's local
verses that we could have played oh
really
someone had a controller maybe or
something yeah i don't
yeah i suppose you would have to okay so
we have pompeii
oh that sounds good do that yeah i'm in
for it
um sweet oh my god holy
[ __ ] more like unholy [ __ ] oh
no one looks happy there dude get like
double ply toilet paper you've clearly
wrecked that b-hole
[Music]
whoa i have no idea what i'm supposed to
do
[Music]
is it me versus me
oh you oh
oh that's pretty neat come on
fireworks during pompeii how just how it
was recorded
look everyone we're gonna die
oh i like this quick dab so you can be
frozen in ash for the next millennia
dab it it's a race
it's a race against history this is
pretty neat
i want to go inside that mine but i feel
like that's not a thing i can do
it does look enticing oh that guy take a
little short dude is he cheating
is this that show cheaters oh
risky i don't know what i'm doing oh i
could have made it
yeah come on bust
bossed uh
oh dude what is he doing he's so good
i want to be his friend show off god
he's like that popular kid in class
that i hate but i love watching him be
so cool right
god you're so cool guys that's such a
perfect sphere
oh this is better
oh can you do a little a little shortcut
there
yeah baby think that's hurting you
damn a poor ball all right i say you
give it one more shot
i say i'm already doomed
show off all right let's do one more
race i'll pick a map that's less uh
let's say difficult less lava e less uh
yeah
i believe this is a level based on van
gogh
i think you're right oh hey what are you
tar boulder jump to stain the enemy
field
oh defensive units cannot be built on
stained
tiles the depth reveals itself
it sure does but it doesn't do me any
good here how did you get that from
playing off i have no idea what the hell
is that chicken house
thing yeah this level is beautiful yeah
this is a cool looking game
where am i supposed to be going i have a
feeling that this ice
may be a little difficult to turn
on a little shortcut dog
oh we're going we don't need roads uh-oh
nope i feel fine it's easy like sunday
morning oh
[ __ ] i can't turn the camera fast
you're good you're still good you're
still good where's
buddy is he following me
oh crawl oh that black ice they talk
about oh
damn don't drop me in the drink
oh no dude guy dude the guy
got it he knew how to handle the ice oh
he grew up in new england
damn that last one's a doozy
hate dinosaurs oh right those are new
you know the situation in the end yeah
but the the problem is how do i
circumvent i think
i think the quote unquote situation
speed baby
speed baby yeah you got a kid
murder it ended with murder nice let's
call it all right we're gonna call it
this has been rock of ages
uh the dose number two from
atlas and pretty neat it's a fun game
there's uh
clearly some stuff going on here that i
don't know about yet yeah so maybe i'll
keep playing
very nice okay well thank you very much
peter and thank you guys for watching if
you guys want to see more let's play
videos like this give us a like and a
sub
take care guys